here's what i do i definitely want to
ask you about some of your policies and
stuff like this but i want to show you
this graph
and i want to ask you about black lives
matter so this is the
overall support versus opposition and
neither support nor opposed unsure and
what i want to do is show net support so
this
is where black lives matter stands right
now
this is a really interesting thing i
noticed that before the george floyd
incident happened
17 net support for black lives matter
it peaked around 25 when you know the
george flanagan happened everybody was
shocked i mean sean hannity
had come out and said this is wrong i
can't believe i was shocked yeah
then they riot and they write more and
they write more and they write more and
now today
net support is six points lower
at 11 than where it was before
the george flight incident yeah so first
i'll just ask you about
the riots because these a lot of people
like to say antifa right
but i've i've said no way man these
people are chanting black lives matter
yeah they're going on portland with
molotovs in seattle they're doing it in
the name of
black lives matter not antifa not you
know marxism or whatever
you know people think it's literally
about police brutality and issues like
george floyd
i'm just curious on your thoughts on
that and then you know i got another
question for you
yeah absolutely so first of all i am not
a fan of black lives matter
you know it's interesting i don't know
many uh black americans that are fans
of black lives matter you know very
interesting fact there
um for me this is a situation where i
feel like there's definitely an agenda
if you look at it and you know in 2015
after the death of freddie gray we had
our riots
and the i was there and uh adam you met
him earlier he was there too okay yeah
so you saw it up close and personal um
and a lot of people that were arrested
were people that didn't even live there
right the bad actors are almost being
uh bussed in you know to cause chaos
and then they leave and they go to
another city and do the same
um and so it's very interesting to me i
don't think it's a real organization
i think it's a front for something else
i'm not gonna again i'm not into
conspiracy theories
um i hear the president's trump's
administration's investigating it
really yeah so i'm i'm interested to see
what happens because i i know that i
think they have
what's it called it's called like
thousand currents i think oh i'm not
sure i'll tell you the there's
yeah yeah definitely there's an
organization that collects money on
their behalf
okay and then it goes through act blue
here's what's fascinating to me
we keep hearing from people like i think
de blasio said this i could be wrong but
there's been several organizations
saying black lives matter is not a
political
organization it's social justice but
their fundraising
goes through act blue which sure does
yeah it's the democrats fundraising
organization right so you're gonna tell
me it's not political it's literally
running money through their fundraising
arm
i know a lot of people have had you know
thought there's a bigger conspiracy
about
people going into black lives matter
that goes to biden or something i don't
think that's true
because that would be a weird that it's
got to be completely illegal
to like take donations for black lives
matter and give it to a political
candidate i don't think
maybe there's something there but uh it
definitely seems
strange to say the least i don't know if
you if you knew this but there was a
there was another black lives matter
foundation based out of i think
california that formed
in 2014 and it's very small and the guys
brought in like a couple hundred
thousand dollars over the past several
years
and it was just one black dude who was
like i got an idea i'm gonna run an
organization i'm gonna raise money
and he said his goal is to bring the
police and the communities together
so that you know the police can be more
familiar with the people who live there
and they can know who their police are
and he was basically saying you know the
proximity and the and you know the the
familiarity will help resolve a lot of
the tensions you know like a cop's less
likely to attack somebody if he knows
the neighborhood and he might know who
that person is
right i'm not gonna know everybody but
here's the crazy thing they they went
after him
and apparently some activists got like
an injunction to like freeze his
donations
gofundme or something like that like
seized his
like fundraiser and gave it to the other
organization
yeah that to me was crazy i mean i don't
know is it because it was also black
lives matter and they owned that right
okay well i don't think they own it
because he had it first they just came
out and said he's not the real one and
he's like but i've had the name
first oh yeah yeah that's interesting
that's interesting i'll tell you i'll
tell you what's interesting you uh
you mentioned you don't know anybody any
you said you didn't know any black
people who supported black lives matter
like for the most part i don't know yeah
i don't take a look at this this is what
i wanted to ask you about i find this is
this is interesting
so this is civics it's got 162 220
responses from
april 25th 2017 to september 9 2020 and
they say
do you sub uh from right among
registered voters black or african
american
88 say they support black lives matter
that's interesting yeah and uh then we
got five percent opposed
so that's interesting i i don't know how
i don't know the 88
maybe it's not maybe it's not real yeah
i guess
this is what um this is what i say and
people that i know say
like you said it goes through act blue
right the money yeah does
have there any been any instances
where any of that money has actually
gone to the black community
i i don't i don't think so in terms of
anything i've seen in the news or i
haven't found anything i've i've tried
to do some research well
you know what they do because i've this
is my insight into all these non-profits
it's a very very clever way to claim
that
all of the money is for charitable
causes awareness
oh yes oh i love those big corporations
right
when you look at apple you look at
different organizations they put a
hundred million dollars
into inclusive training right that the
whole like
oh we're going to talk about how to
meanwhile you look at how many black
people they have in like their top
executive positions two percent two
percent
like so you really care about black
lives because you don't you don't
hire any black people right you're not
employing them and i'm not saying people
should be employed based on their color
but that i find that interesting you
know there's a lot of corporations that
say they have this this
training and they're raising awareness
um
but then you look at their executive
offices and you don't
see any people of color it's it's
corporations trying to shield themselves
from the latest trend right it's going
to backfire on them really really bad
there was a post i just saw recently i
can't remember who it was from but i
think
something like the new york times wrote
a story saying like we mapped the most
powerful people in the country
and it's like 18 percent are non-white
and i think it was the new york times
and then someone showed that all the top
new york times staff it's all white
people
so so they they want to act like we're
we you know we're pointing out a serious
problem but don't look where we are
yeah it's seriously the rules for thee
but not for me it's like everything they
do
yeah no seriously i i was shocked when i
saw twitter
um there they had their their main
twitter support page right
and it was all blacked out like they're
so supportive but we already
knew it was already ousted i think a
year ago that they didn't hire
any black people so it's like you know i
i don't understand it i don't get it i
know they're not trying to be a part of
that canceled culture so they're
covering their butts but
um i don't think they realize people
aren't stupid you know
we see it so i don't know how we got to
this 88 but i
i better do my due diligence and figure
it out you there's a possibility that
you're in a bubble
and you're just not yeah around the
people that could be
you know west baltimore all black
now you have not in a bubble yeah you
have right right right
i have to ask though you know because
yeah no you know
i think a lot of these journalists don't
realize they're definitely in a bubble
oh my gosh yes yes this is
oh i so i get in a fight all the time
with you know richard fowler on fox news
no no no no oh my gosh who is he he
kills me so
he's a guy um that basically lives
at fox news studio right and he likes to
come on and tell people he's a black guy
about how hard it is to be black in
america i'm like
dude when is the last time you've ever
been
in a predominantly black neighborhood he
couldn't answer that he could not
and supposedly he's from uh chicago but
not like
chicago chicago because gianno caldwell
uh called him out on it and i don't know
what the name of the town was
i bet it's naperville or something he
was like these are like the west suburbs
yeah he was like dude you're not from
chicago don't you close chicago
you know but it's there is there's a lot
of people in the media
that lives what's his name again richard
richard fowler
yes i actually was just in a fight with
him uh just last week on fox news what'd
you guys argue about
um well he was trying to tell me how
great biden was
but he was also telling me how america's
policies were so racist and i'm like
interesting
so biden had 50 years to change some of
those racist policies but he didn't
so yeah and he was vice president for
obama yeah so tell me
tell me again how is he for black people
the guy that did the 1994 crime bill
yes yeah super yeah he's that guy i
couldn't figure out where he was from on
a
glance but being from chicago there's
always people who say um they'll be like
oh i'm from chicago and i'll say oh cool
which part well naperville oh oh
it's evanston evanston yes
look i'm not going to pretend like
evanston is the wealthiest place in the
world but it's it's
i'm pretty sure it's like a north north
side and it's nice
yeah it's pretty nice yeah and uh there
are definitely nicer nicer
areas of chicago for sure but to if you
tell someone you're from evanston
they're going to be like wow where did
your parents work like they must have
great jobs
yeah people from the south side of
chicago and they'll be like ah you know
slinging burgers and
working in the coal mines huh yeah so
but
but i will point something out to be
fair although i don't think this
impacted him
it's really interesting we have this
defund the police narrative alexandria
ocasio-cortez was asked about
what she envisions this you know will
look like if you defund the police and
she says the suburbs
it's really funny when first just to
provide a critique on that
well the suburbs aren't as densely
populated as the cities so you have less
people per square mile so
sure you'll need less police it just
makes sense and
uh but more to the point to be fair
uh people from the poor years actually
go to the go to the north side and go to
the wealthier areas to
to commit crimes because you can't rob
poor people right
but you do have more violent crime in
the poor areas because of the conflict
between people
right so if you if you live in a place
like evanston
i don't think you're really in a
position to criticize someone about
living in a hard area and yeah
yeah to be fair too i was reading a
tweet from
uh it was a woman she was white and she
was talking about misconceptions around
crime and for people who grow up
in places like actually i'll ask you
your feelings on this in a second i grew
up on the southwest side
it was kind of bad not the worst because
there's other parts of the south side
and the west side that are way worse
but there were shootings there were drug
overdoses and stuff and it was normal to
us
so when when when gangbangers would pull
up and start firing guns or when fights
were break out people were armed we were
kind of just like
this is normal life where we are and
then when you tell that to other people
they're shocked to hear it and they're
scared
of it not realizing that it's not like
every day someone comes out with a gun
that's firing in the air
right but you hear gunshots at night you
know periodically
so i'm wondering uh you know is it
similar
being in west baltimore with the
normalization of
potential violence and things like that
it's very similar it's to the point
where
shots are fired and nobody even turns
around
you know what i mean no one turns around
but a lot of people understand and this
is what i come to
understand um just so you know i've been
spending a lot of time on the streets
because i want to truly
understand from their point of view um
but people will say we know it's usually
a retaliation
situation and if i'm not in it usually
that bull is for someone else
right yeah and i think it's sad that you
know that is the norm
you know to walk up and down the streets
and to see all the needles to see just
everything out there and to them it's
normal
kids walking past it to school normal
day
just walking up the street and so that's
what it becomes like the quality of life
becomes normalized
and it's getting worse and worse and so
when you're pointing out the trash
you know you got some people that were
saying well how dare you point out
those streets we know they're they're
filled with trash we're used to that
you know it's like you know you don't
have to live this way right you know it
shouldn't be like this
you know there shouldn't be 17 000
vacant homes
just sitting there i mean it's it's
insane to me
but i understand it because like you
said it's
normal everyday life did elijah cummings
live in the district
um supposedly he did so this is the
crazy part about the district
there's howard county in baltimore
county and then west baltimore
howard county is a very wealthy area
right and then you have baltimore county
you go up north it goes all the way up
to the pennsylvania line
again very wealthy so when this was
redistricted in 2013
it looked as if he was doing great
because you had these wealthy areas
attached to west baltimore and then he
could live in the wealthy area away from
exactly and so when people get on me and
they're like well she doesn't exactly
live there and i'm thinking
yeah i could live in a mansion over in
parkton if you want
you know or i could spend a lot of time
in west baltimore trying to understand
the issues
yeah what would you like to come at me
with you know what i learned about uh
chicago one of the one of the problems
with solving the problem one of the one
of the problems
in solving the problems is that if
the people who live there are not
receiving any kind of support from their
locals and they're just going about
their lives and there's trash everywhere
and there's violence what i hear from
people outside saying we're going to
solve this problem
and you ask them do do you know why
there's violence in chicago
and i don't put you on the spot but i'm
curious what your thoughts are not
living in chicago
do you know what the cause of you've
heard about chicago gun violence and
like
iraq do you know what causes the
violence
i would think everything around it right
the education system
the lack of opportunity the best answer
i've heard so far
because it is it so uh people always say
gangs
they people oh yeah they just jump right
up to the g okay they think that
gangs are fighting over terran stuff and
it's not right it really does have to do
with
the living conditions the standard of
living the culture the education
and a lot of so i i went on uh i went
what's called nightcrawling
so a local journalist we met up at like
you know two in the morning or whatever
this sounds so fun already oh man but i
don't know
if you want to be a journalist tracking
murders and stuff and like reporting on
this stuff
yeah so it takes a strong stomach i'll
tell you what and
it's it's it's you're you need a strong
heart and a strong stomach to see some
of these things
but some of the stories that we we went
to it was
uh in one instance somebody had
a personal argument on social media and
so they drove up and started shooting
into a building they thought belonged to
the person and it didn't
and two people were killed another story
uh another uh shooting we found was a
guy was gunned down on the sidewalk
because he was smack talking the other
guy on social media
i kid you not so it turned out a lot of
these killings were basically just
people had beef and they
for whatever reason they were like the
solution to my problems if you talk
smack to me i kill you
right so it really does not have a lot
to do with gangs and if you don't
understand
the the community the culture and how to
solve those problems because you're just
assuming
there's like some some uh buzzword
that can be the easy it's it's like they
think there's an easy
easy solution where it's like if i just
take this one piece out of the puzzle
then
the problem solved not realizing it's
systemic right it's education it's lack
of leadership
and i believe a lot of it has to do with
what we're talking about earlier
when there's one party rule there's no
competition yeah
no one has to come in and say here's my
proposal
and when the locals try they're
completely ignored yeah
i wonder you know and when i hear about
uh when i asked about elijah living in
the
in the in the district do you think that
they gerrymandered on purpose so that
they can live in a wealthy clean area
and then represent and ignore it was
that and then also so you have to
understand also
um in baltimore city we have 13 high
schools
uh where kids graduate unable to do uh
basic math or read or write right
and so a lot of those schools are in the
west baltimore area but if you put those
on with the schools in howard county
which are great
right and in baltimore county sparks all
that then it doesn't look like the
schools
are that bad right so it was literally
like
they were just making sure like okay
yeah we got this problem but
you know put the good areas over it
hopefully nobody sees but it averages
out
exactly and that's what it was about and
that's what it was about and so
um governor martin o'malley actually
admitted to redistricting some areas to
do
you know that and so now yeah they're
going to look at drawing the lines but
this is why
chipping away is so important because if
they redistrict
and you've been chipping away in some of
these areas and
it actually makes sense like okay howard
county and baltimore county they have a
lot more in common than
anybody in west baltimore when they
redistrict chipping away might equal in
a republican win you know and so it's
like but if we don't chip away
again we're just not in the running so
it's just and just to clarify the idea
of chipping away it's just
trying to build up as much support for
the republicans
slowly even if it's a little bit yes and
then it takes work
i know a lot of people don't you know i
understand politics not everybody in
government wants to work
but it does it takes grassroot efforts
it takes you getting out there and
working every single day
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time